- LOOK RAJID,
I'M GONNA MAKE THIS
REALLY NICE AND EASY FOR YOU.
I NEED NAMES AND YOU'RE GONNA
GIVE 'EM TO ME.
- YOU HAVE TO LISTEN TO ME.
YOU HAVE TO LISTEN TO ME.
THIS IS ALL A HUGE MISTAKE.
- BULL[bleep]!
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY'S
BEEN MONITORING YOUR CALLS
FOR WEEKS, RAJID.
WE GOT YOU.
WE KNOW ABOUT YOU
AND YOUR FRIENDS.
WE KNOW THAT YOU'RE A--
- TERRIERIST.
I AM A TERRIERIST.
WE--ME AND MY FRIENDS,
WE BREED DOGS,
SPECIFICALLY TERRIERS.
WE WRITE TERRIERIST FICTION.
WE SPEND A GOOD DEAL OF TIME
DISCUSSING POSSIBLE FUTURE
TERRIERIST PLOTS--
[groans]
- HMM.
THAT'S A NICE TRY.
IT REALLY IS.
BUT IT'S BULL[bleep], RAJID!
COME ON.
IS THAT THE BEST YOU GOT?
NOW COME ON, I'M LISTENING.
JUST TELL ME.
TELL ME.
TELL ME ABOUT
THIS IMMINENT ATTACK.
- WHAT? WHAT?
WHAT ATTACK?
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
- WHAT ARE YOU T--WHAT AM I
TALKING ABOUT?
- I DON'T--
- I DON'T KNOW, HUH? HUH?
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
- I'M TELLING YOU--
- NO, YOU DON'T KNOW?
- I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW.
- JUNE 11, RAJID.
YOU SPOKE OF AN IMMINENT ATTACK.
- OH, OH, YES. NO.
LISTEN, THAT WAS MY FRIEND.
LISTEN, HIS DOG BIT HIM.
- NO.
- AND I TOLD HIM,
"IF YOU DO NOT TRAIN THEM..."
- NO.
- "ANOTHER TERRIER ATTACK
IS IMMINENT."
[grunts]
- SO YOU LIE
AND YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS?
- I DON'T--
I'M NOT LYING TO YOU.
- COME ON, RAJID.
I LIKE YOU.
LET'S BE FRIENDS, HUH?
NOW YOU STILL
HAVEN'T EXPLAINED TO ME
WHY WE FOUND, ON THE SEARCH
ENGINE OF YOUR COMPUTER,
THE WORDS "TARGET WASHINGTON"
49 TIMES.
- THAT--THAT IS BECAUSE
I WAS IN D.C. FOR A DOG SHOW
AND I HAD TO BUY A SQUEEZY TOY,
A BIRTHDAY CARD,
AND SOME DEODORANT
ALL AT AN AFFORDABLE PRICE.
- ALL RIGHT.
- YOU CAN ONLY
DO THAT AT TARGET.
- YEAH, OKAY.
I SEE HOW YOU WANNA PLAY THIS.
- [groans]
- THIS IS NOT A CASE
OF MISTAKEN IDENTITY, RAJID,
AND YOU KNOW IT!
WE'VE HEARD THE CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN YOU AND JAFAR.
WHERE YOU DISCUSSING YOUR HATRED
OF AMERICAN IDEALS.
- NO, NO, IDOLS.
AMERICAN IDOLS!
I-I HATE THEM.
THEY PERFORMED DANCING QUEEN.
IT WAS A DESECRATION TO ABBA.
MY FAVORITE BAND.
- WE GOT YOU ON TAPE
REFERRING TO JAFAR
AS ONE OF THE ARCHITECTS OF--
- 7-ELEVEN!
IT WAS 7-ELEVEN!
JAFAR--HE DESIGNS
CONVENIENCE STORES.
- 7-ELEVEN?
OH, [bleep].
- WILSON, 65 DOGS JUST ATTACKED
THE CAPITOL BUILDING.
- WERE THEY TERRIERS?
- HOW DID YOU KNOW?
- [bleep]!
- PRAISE ABBA.